[Musique]
nouvelle édition du café politique
bonjour il ya une bonne souris et
bienvenue au web to you toujours à
montigny le bretonneux face au vélodrome
vous êtes présidente de la commission
des lois de l'assemblée nationale vous
êtes député déi v sous l'étiquette la
république en marche vous avez été élu
l'année dernière ça fait un an
maintenant 18 juin 2017 dans la
cinquième 5ème circonscription votre
adversaire lors du scrutin c'était
jacques myard républicain en poste
depuis 24 ans on sait qu'il n'a pas
forcément bien accepter la défaite
est-ce que vous avez échangé avec lui
depuis alors non pas du tout je le vois
lors des cérémonies officielles et où il
me réserve toujours un accueil très
républicain mais nos relations se sont
arrêtés là après un an donc de postes à
cette fonction de député est ce que vous
êtes satisfaite du travail mené on en
parlera un peu plus tout à l'heure mais
dans les grandes lignes déjà aujourd'hui
cette première année de mandat alors
dans les grandes lignes c'était un
mandat qui est passionnant un moment clé
je pense dans l'histoire de notre pays
on sent qu'il ya une vraie dynamique de
changement qui s'est installée donc je
suis heureuse et très fière de pouvoir y
participer
et puis
j'adore être sur le terrain j'adore être
au contact des citoyens donc le fait de
pouvoir rencontrer les gens allaient
dans la circonscription au contact est
quelque chose qui me satisfait
pleinement donc les sur ces deux aspects
c'est une mission qui me convient
parfaitement
à 47 ans vous avez une autre vie
auparavant professionnel vous avez
étudié le droit avant d'être avocate au
barreau de paris
pourquoi vous êtes tourner ensuite vers
la politique parce que c'est une longue
histoire qui est qui est faite
d'engagement comme comme un petit peu je
pense tout le monde
puis les engagements sont divers donc
des engagements d'abord au service de
causes lorsque l'on est avocat on défend
des clients après
je me suis engagé auprès de mes enfants
je me suis arrêté quelques années pour
les élever donc là j'ai des engagements
très scolaire parents d'élèves membres
des conseils d'administration etc
puis un engagement très fort au niveau
associatif donc au niveau des plus
démunis et puis un engagement politique
un engagement pour l'ensemble des
citoyens
donc c'est plutôt ça la ligne
conductrice et l'engagement pour les
autres et les autres ont un petit peu
varié tout au long de ma vie
et pourquoi la république en marche la
république en marche parce que la
république en marche représentait ce que
j'espérais en politique c'est à dire une
vision pragmatique des questions des
problèmes
quelque chose qui réunit les gens quels
que soient justement leurs origines
politiques leurs opinions avec le
souhait de poser les choses de réfléchir
d'échanger de débattre et d'essayer de
construire des solutions pour l'avenir
donc c'était cette vision là qui m'a
semblé être particulièrement
intéressante et surtout particulièrement
efficace à ce moment clé de l'histoire
de notre pays
et quel regard vous aviez sur la
politique auparavant ça ne répondait pas
à vos attentes les autres formations
politiques ne répondait pas à vos
attentes
alors oui c'est cela moi j'étais
toujours intéressé par la politique donc
j'ai toujours suivi cela de près mais
les positions en fait très dogmatique de
certains partis sur certaines questions
me laissait un petit peu pantoise moi je
trouvais que il ne fallait pas réfléchir
de la sorte et qu'il fallait vraiment à
chaque fois reposés les choses et
essayer de voir quels étaient les
objectifs qu'on souhaitait atteindre
quels étaient les problématiques et que
ses objectifs est problématique et les
solutions qui en découlaient ne
dépendait pas d'une étiquette politique
mais vraiment d'une réflexion d'un
échange de débat et c'est pour ça que je
me suis tout de suite reconnu dans la
république en marche
alors parlons de cette fonction de
présidente de la commission des lois à
l'assemblée nationale vous n'êtes que la
deuxième femme à accéder à cette
fonction
comment vous l'expliquez déjà même
envolé très difficile toujours le monde
politique est toujours très difficile
pour les femmes même si la situation
s'est grandement améliorée mais quand on
regarde les postes clés de l'état ils
ont quand même été toujours occupés par
des hommes n'y a jamais eu de président
de femmes de l'assemblée nationale la
présidente femmes du sénat une femme
premier ministre peu de temps et pas de
présidente femmes de la république donc
je pense que on a encore du chemin à
parcourir mais nous à la république en
marche on est prêts de 48% députés à
l'assemblée nationale donc on a fait un
grand pas dans la parité et comme vous
l'avez rappelé on a fait la parité
également dans les présidences de
commissions donc je suis la deuxième
femme et ce qui est plutôt rigolo de
noter c'est que la précédente qui
s'appelait tasca était également des
yvelines donc voilà les yvelines marque
la commission des lois entre cas dans
son caractère féminin parler de ce monde
politique difficile pour pour les femmes
on vous a fait justement des procès en
incompétence on vous a prêté aussi
d'avoir dit vouloir vous occuper de vos
enfants le mercredi
vous les avez vécu comment ces remarques
ben j'ai trouvé que c'était très injuste
parce que l on été fait dès mon arrivée
donc avant même que je puisse montrer à
tout le monde ma capacité à exercer
cette fonction est l dénotait d'un a
priori très misogyne sur le fait que
puisque c'était une femme qui arrivait à
cette fonction par nature elle
s'occuperait ses enfants elle
réaliserez mal sa mission ou encore plus
plus plus récemment un député a
mady a trouvé que mes remontrances était
maternelle donc il ya toujours ce renvoi
à cette figure maternelle et c'est
peut-être ça qui fait que les femmes ont
du mal à accéder à certains postes
en politique il ya toujours cette cette
vision là qui malheureusement perdu
ouverture d'esprit fibre sociale aussi
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui vous
définit bien je vais quand même préciser
que vous avez été bénévole aux restos du
coeur
voilà à chanteloup-les-vignes ça
consistait en quoi c'est ce bénévolat
est alors j'ai rejoint les restos du
coeur pour m'occuper de l'accès à la
justice puisque c'était mon ancienne
profession d'avocate et donc l'idée
c'était de faire bénéficier les
personnes donc les plus démunis qui
fréquentent les restos du coeur de
conseil juridique et elles en ont
beaucoup besoin puisqu'elles sont
parfois en difficulté d'expulsion en
difficulté de paiement de pension
alimentaire etc
après donc j'ai démarré cette activité
et j'avais envie d'être proche des gens
j'avais envie d'être sur le terrain et
donc le responsable départemental des
restos du coeur m'a proposé dont de
gérer en centre et j'ai été géré un
centre à chanteloup-les-vignes donc au
milieu de la cité et après j'ai
développé donc l'activité accès à la
justice mais je suis devenu responsable
national de l'accès à la justice pour
les restos du coeur et en même temps de
l'accès aux droits sociaux pour essayer
traquer le non recours et en même temps
j'ai ouvert le centre de sartrouville
qui est tout de suite devenu le plus
gros centre des restos du coeur des
yvelines et où j'ai pu côtoyer tous les
jours des personnes en extrême
difficulté mais en même temps avoir
cette chaleur humaine ce contact qui
pour moi est indispensable avec c'est
pas le contact avec la réalité mais
c'est vraiment contact humain et on se
rend compte en plus dans une association
telle que les restos que l'accueil la
chaleur la discussion la proximité est
fondamental pour des gens qui sont en
grande précarité et vous avez le
sentiment qu'aujourd'hui la politique
menée par le gouvernement répond pas aux
attentes de ces personnes en difficulté
alors oui je lai profondément
contrairement à ce qu'ont ce qu'on
pourrait dire parce que
lorsque on s'adresse à ces populations
il faut les aider et leur proposer un
avenir leur proposer des projets d issue
et donc ses projets ses issues on peut
les trouver à travers la formation
professionnelle à travers un retour à
l'emploi parce que ça c'est du long
terme
et puis on peut le trouver en donnant un
avenir aux enfants et donner un avenir
aux enfants c'est mettre l'accent sur
l'éducation
et quand je vois les résultats
apparemment extraordinaire qu'on
commence à avoir sur les dédoublements
de classes dans les petites classes pour
que l'apprentissage de la lecture de
l'écriture etc ce terrain on se rend
compte que là on travaille sur le long
terme on travaille sur le fond et on le
travaille sur leur avenir
donc je trouve que oui on a une
politique extrêmement social mais social
au fond des choses et en plus on a une
politique sociale très concrète face à
des personnes qui elles sont dans des
situations qui nous elles ne peuvent pas
bénéficier de ces retours à l'emploi
type l'allocation adulte handicapé qu'on
a augmenté le minimum vieillesse qui
concerne des personnes âgées extrêmement
fragile et pour lequel également ont
fait un effort conséquent
donc oui on s'adresse à toutes les
personnes qui sont en situation de
précarité il faut sans doute le faire
plus le faire encore mieux
davantage mais je trouve que là on n'ait
vraiment justement sur des très bonnes
pistes parce qu'elles sont vraiment
extrêmement profonde le dossier qui vous
occupe le plus en ce moment c'est
peut-être la réforme constitutionnelle
oui tout à fait on ne fait pas
l'unanimité c'est de toute façon là la
marque de tous les textes en fait qu'ils
sont soumis au parlement
ils sont toujours modifier amendé et la
navette entre nos deux chambres chez que
les textes évolué progresse pour
atteindre à un moment où ils sont
consensuelles donc bien évidemment au
début de la phase parlementaire le texte
ne fait pas la une
limité mais justement tout notre travail
va pouvoir commencer dès la semaine
prochaine
le président du sénat lui n'approuve pas
totalement ce qui était proposé
alors mais c'est bien normal maintenant
nous allons échanger avec lui je sais
qu'il a beaucoup échangé avec le
président de la république et avec le
président de l'assemblée nationale
maintenant la phase parlementaire va
vraiment commencer avec le travail des
rapporteurs dans les deux chambres et je
ne doute pas un seul instant que nos
travaux conjoints pourront mener à une
solution qui satisfera les deux chambres
parce que elle elle sera dans l'intérêt
du parlement puisqu'on parle un petit
peu de l'actualité et il nous reste
quelques instants je voudrais parler de
vos propositions sur la réforme
carcérale
quel sombre dans les grandes lignes les
possibilités d'agir rapidement pour
changer le système carcéral parce qu'on
sait qu'aujourd'hui
ne serait-ce que les prisons sont
saturés déjà alors nos prisons sont
saturés les derniers chiffres ne sont
pas bons avec un peu plus de 70 mille
détenus et une surpopulation 1 118 %
donc il ya plusieurs leviers parce que
bien évidemment il n'y en a pas qu'un
seul s'il n'y en avait qu'un seul il
aurait été utilisée depuis longtemps
donc il va falloir agir sur les deux
niveaux sur les deux plateaux de la
balance en fait avoir une construction
d'établissements pénitentiaires et moi
je propose à cet égard la réhabilitation
de bâtiments existants ou des
constructions de structure beaucoup plus
allégée en termes de sécurité pour
accueillir des détenus non dangereux sur
des petites peines ou des fins de peine
et ça ces bâtiments peuvent aller très
rapidement dans leur construction
et parallèlement il faut qu'on développe
absolument tout ce qui est pas
d'alternative pour baisser le nombre
d'entrants dans les prisons donc en
agissant sur ces deux leviers on va
pouvoir faire baisser durablement
l'attention sur nos établissements
pénitentiaires ce qui est essentiel
parce que des établissements
pénitentiaires qui rate l'étape de la
réinsertion
c'est un échec collectif parce que c'est
plus de récidive et donc c'est des
victimes de demain donc il faut vraiment
que la société entière se préoccupe de
cette question et c'est vraiment
peut-être le combat que je vais mener
pendant toute ma présidence de
commission des lois et au delà bien sûr
avec un nom brigade mans
en tout cas des des idées radicales qui
se développe quelquefois je sais
certains détenus lors de leur passage en
prison aussi alors tout à fait vous avez
raison il ya un vrai problème qu'en ce
qui concerne les radicaliser en prison
avec le phénomène de contagion sur le
reste de la détention que cela peut
produire
donc il y a actuellement beaucoup de
choses qui sont mises en place dans nos
prisons pour lutter contre ce phénomène
là en ayant des quartiers beaucoup plus
étanche qui fasse que les cds tenu là ne
puisse pas faire de prosélytisme en
détention une dernière question pour
terminer et j'en viens à votre parcours
personnel cette fois ci vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure vous avez suivre votre
marier dans un cadre professionnel vous
avez aussi vos enfants 5 à 0
votre famille aujourd'hui vit bien le
fait que vous soyez engager autant aux
politiques ils sont extrêmement fiers de
moi extrêmement soutenant parce que
voilà ils savent que je leur ai consacré
du temps et donc maintenant il voit là
ils m'encouragent et me soutiennent et
c'est formidable pour moi mais
indispensable autrement je crois que je
ne pourrais pas le faire
merci beaucoup et elles vont arriver
d'avoir participé à ce café politique
merci à vous
[Musique]
et